Salut, aujourd'hui je suis dans les loges de l'Européen, parce que je fais la 1ère partie de Lamine Lezghad
Et figurez vous que dans les loges de l'Européen j'ai retrouvé
Nico et Esteban
vous vous souvenez c'est eux qui captaient l'Inglorious  Comedy Club de Vérino
et ils captent aussi maintenant le spectacle de Lamine. Vous êtes partout les mecs
Vous êtes dans le game, vous êtes dans le game de ouf
Donc cesoir, je vais faire ma 1ère partie filmé et je vous met les images
*Applaudissement*
Il y a quelques années quand j'étais comme ça sur scène et que je disais aux gens que j'étais mentaliste
personne ne savait ce que c'était
et maintenant qui y a eu la série The Mentalist, personne ne sait ce que sait ça a rien changer du tout
Cesoir on va commencé doucement, on va commencé avec de la graphologie
j'ai avec moi 3 cartes de visites au dos desquelles j'ai mis un questionnaire
J'aime 2 points etc...
Je vais les donner à 3 d'entres vous.
Les personnes qui veulent vraiment participer ce soir, vous pouvez lever la main.
ce qui n'arrive jamais
sauf sur les gens chelous comme toi
*rires
vous remplissez de manière honnête et surtout secrète
pour que ni moi, ni personne dans la salle ne puissions lire ce que vous avez noté.
Lisa, Samy et Benoit.
Pendant ce temps je vais prendre quelqu'un au hasard
Au hasard parmi Hervé.
*rire*
On connais tous son prénom. On va faire un grand tour de magie ensemble Hervé, un truc qui a cartonné y'a 2000ans
Hervé lève toi et marche
*rires*
Je vais t'expliquer le tour de magie qu'on va faire, tu vas être dégoûté.
Le tour de magie c'est que tu vas juste tout ramasser pour moi et me rendre les cartes
Les 3 cartes face en bas pour pas que je puisse lire ce qu'ils ont marqués
tu les mélanges un peu, tu me les rends
et faut aussi que tu récupères les 3 stylos bic noir. Tu sais pourquoi Hervé?
C'est la crise pour tout le monde. Pour moi aussi Hervé
Hervé regarde regarde cette sensation tu es sur la scène de l'Européen Hervé
Vous pouvez l'applaudir Hervé
Tu vas pouvoir raconter à tout le monde que déjà tu t'es fait carotte un stylo
La mission elle n'était pas dur, Hervé
C'est pas compliqué mais je sais déjà que c'est Samy
Tu es monté sur scène ce soir, mon petit Hervé, n'est pas peur comme ça
tu as le droit de prendre une décision. La décision elle est simple, c'est est ce que tu veux rendre l'expérience de ce soir encore plus compliqué?
Alors à eux
Hervé: Oui
F: Très fort
H: OUI
F: ou non, c'est un choix c'est le tien
alors est ce que tu veux qu'on rende ça encore plus compliqué?
H: Non
*rires*
Ça ça s'appelle avoir une volonté en pâte à modeler
Hervé tu avais dit oui au départ
ne te laisse pas influencer par qui que ce soit
Tu récupère une des 3 cartes celle que tu veux, mais la retourne pas, pour pas que je puisse la lire.
tu en as une là?
Ok alors tu vas t’asseoir à ta place avec et tout en marchant tu l'as déchire Hervé
en marchant tu l'as déchire, en marchant... tu l'as déchire
2 actions en même temps Hervé ça va ou pas?
*rires*
Je vois que vous avez écrit des choses différentes, avec des univers différents
J'aime bien celle ci. Celle ci je sais déjà que c'est un homme qui l'a écrit
parce ça en graphologie c'est un terme technique pour ça, on dit que c'est écris comme un cochon. Et nous les gars on écrit très mal.
il as écrit tout en majuscule en plus
Il a fait un petit smiley en dehors des lignes, en dehors du cadre après j'aime 2 points
ça c'est un signe d'intelligence et de vivacité d'esprit
C'est bien parce que là j'ai Benoit et Samy qui font: "Je veux pas te vexer mais je crois que"
*rires*
Ça marche sur vous 2 les gars pour l'instant
je pense que la personne qui a écrit "J'aime la blonde que tu as dragué"
Je n'ai dragué personne mais je pense que c'est toi Samy qui a écrit ça
Si c'est le cas dis moi oui très fort et assis toi
Samy: Oui très fort assied toi
F: Merci beaucoup Samy
*applaudissement*
Alors le plus difficle de le faire c'est étape par étape à chaque fois j'augmente la difficulté d'un pouce
ce coup ci je vais vous poser à tout les 2 la même question, quoi qu'il arrive vous direz "Non ce n'est pas moi"
comme ça un des 2 va forcément me mentir
honneur au dame. Euh... Lisa est ce tu as commencé par écrire j'aime les artichauts
Lisa: Non ce n'est pas moi
Vous avez pas vu mais elle as fait : "Non c'est pas moi" *en bougeant la tête de droite à gauche* elle a tout le corps qui a fait non
tu sais ce que tu as fait ça s’appelle un pléonasme physique
je vous le dit si vous voyez un jour quelqu'un qui à le corps qui fait ce que sa voix dit. C'est que cette personne là en général dis la vérité
ou alors que c'est une grosse mytho
*rires*
et là on sait pas encore je vais poser la même question à Benoit
Benoit quoi qu'il arrive tu dis non ce n'est pas moi
est ce que tu as commencé
Benoit: Non c'est pas moi
*rires*
F: Te précipite pas, c'est suspect quand même
est ce que tu as commencé par écrire j'aime les artichauts?
B: Non ce n'est pas moi
F: Alors là c'est intéressant, tu peux le redire un coup?
F: Bonne tête de psychopathe toi par contre
*rires*
F: J'ai pas envie de te contredire. Mes dons de mentaliste me permette de vous affirmer une chose ce soir. C'est que quelqu'un ment
Si ça, ça te bluffe madame tu vas adoré la suite
Je crois que la personne qui ment qui a vraiment écrit j'aime les artichauts, qui va dire la vérité maintenant
je pense que c'est toi Benoit. Si c'est le cas dis moi oui très fort et assis toi
B: Oui c'est moi
F: Merci beaucoup Benoit
*applaudissement*
Lisa elle est toujours debout en mode. Ok moi j'ai fait tout ça pour rien
Tu n'as pas fait tout ça pour rien. Jamais personne ne fait quelque chose pour rien avec moi
C'est pour ça que tu vas me rejoindre sur scène maintenant.
Lisa s'il vous plait
Je vais essayer de retrouver à présent ce que tu as écris après j'aime 2 points
d'accord si tu as écris plusieurs choses après j'aime 2 points tu prends que le 1er mot dans ta tête et tu ne cherche pas à me donner d'indice
d'accord? Tu as... tu as du mal à trouver ton 1er mot c'est ça.
*rire*
C'est vrai?
Alors, non parce que y'a un cas dans lequel on a du mal à trouver son 1er mot. C'est peut-être ça
C'est arrivé une fois
Une seule fois dans toute ma vie. Tu n'as rien écrit.
*Hochement de tête disant oui de Lisa*
F: Elle a rien écrit alors
pour retrouver ce qu'elle a écrit, ça va être compliqué puisqu'elle a rien écrit
est ce que tu sens que je suis un peu dans la merde là en terme de 1ère partie
Il y a des gens qui sont atterrés. Je... je peux pas revenir la dessus Lisa
*rires*
Je propose de jeter des choses sur Lisa
C'est pas grave du coup
Lisa: C'est fini?
F: Ben oui c'est fini... ben oui ben non *se met à rire*
*Rire du public et applaudissement*
Je vous demande quelque chose
Lisa: Non mais au moins vous avez deviné que je n'avais rien écrit
F: C'est pire quand tu cherches à m'aider. Je t'assure
*rires*
Bon écoute on va essayer un truc rapide
j'ai vraiment d'essayer un truc avec toi
*ri*
Tu vas verrouiller ta pensée Lisa, à partir de maintenant tu vas uniquement me répondre par oui ou par non
ok uniquement par oui ou par non est ce que tu es d'accord?
L: Oui
F: Oui tu as réussi le 1er test
*rires*
Tu vas un petit peu les oublier on va aller jusqu'au bout avec toi
Tu es la 3ème personne, tu me regardes dans les yeux
on va jusqu'au bout avec toi, tu as un cadre blanc dans ton esprit avec un prénom qu'il faut que je retrouve
tu me regardes toujours dans les yeux
Ça peut-être ami, famille, travail, autres. Famille d'accord
Tu me regardes toujours dans les yeux.
Père, Mère, Frère, Sœur, autres
c'est entre père et mère
Père
Mère
Elle a les yeux qui : *bouge la tête sur le côté* Mère, mère mère
*rire*
Ne cherche pas à m'aider. Tu vas continuer de visualiser ta mère devant toi et je vais noter pleins de détails sur elle
au fur et à mesure tu me diras si j'ai bon ou pas. D'accord
Quand j'imagine ta mère
*rires*
J'avais pas détecté le potentiel de cette phrase
quand je visualise ta mère
j'imagine quelqu'un avec des yeux... ça c'est bon?
*rire*
On va pas se priver d'une victoire
Quelqu'un du sexe féminin
L:  Oui
F: Là elle aurait pu dire non l'opération c'est bien passé. ça fait plaisir
J'ai un détail qui me viens sur ta mère un détail, un détail personnel presque intime. Je le note ici
Avant de le révéler j'aimerai que tu me la présente. Comme s'appelle ta mère s'il te plait?
Lisa: Christine
F: Ta mère s'appelle Christine. Tu la visualiser bien là maintenant?
On s'en sort parce que moi j'avais écris Christine
F: Un tonnerre d'applaudissement pour Lisa s'il vous plait
*Applaudissement*
Je fais des vidéos sur internet, sur YouTube j'ai un défi durant un an. Du 1er janvier au 31 décembre je fais une vidéo par jour sur YouTube
où j'explique des trucs de mentalisme
J'en fais comme là ce soir ça sera sur YouTube.
Une Vidéo par jour pendant un an
Abonnez vous à ma chaîne YouTube
à très bientôt. Merci Beaucoup
*Applaudissement*
Merci beaucoup
Et ce soir Lamine Lezghad
*applaudissement*